[Musique]
si on ne fait pas ce qu'on aime
on n'existe pas
[Musique]
ces moeurs peut t c'est comme si plus
rien ne comptait pour lui
même pas moi il faut que tu réfléchisses
bien que les gens qui ont besoin de toi
non je vais le faire ce combat victor
dragon bleu pétillant drague ou pia
ignominie apollo creed a aujourd'hui a
lancé à la presse qu'il épiait creed
fais pas ça
faut que je fasse c'est exactement ce
que tomber radis et il est mort juste
après dans mes bras
[Musique]
ce mec a grandi dans la m
il est temps aux joueurs
ce qui a été brisé en moi je m'en suis
jamais remet ça vaut pas le coup
on n'est plus tout seul maintenant je
veux réécrire l'histoire
tu veux combattre cet homme c'est ton
affaire mais ne prétend pas que tu fais
ça pour ton père
[Musique]
m
j survivrait
toi aussi
c'est obligé parce qu'on est unique
[Musique]
maintenant tu sais pourquoi que bach
round après round d'en apprendre plus
sur toi même pu monter sur le ring
[Musique]
c'était pas que pour moi